[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec évidemment un passage obligatoire
on va parler des retraites on va parler
de la grève mais on parlera aussi du
racisme anti vieux et existe-t-il auprès
vous parlera de greta to bear qui est
qui et vous le savez la femme de l'année
selon le times
et vous demandera d'ailleurs si vous
êtes d'accord avec cette décision c'est
celui-ci ocana qui sont pas d'accord il
ya par exemple jean charles lajoie dit
et bien sûr je suis content mais je vous
dirai ça moi ça ne m'étonne pas parce
que vous faites du racisme anti-jeune et
non par votes libye veut le racisme anti
gourde stéphane minson bourgeois trice
vous êtes toujours professeur alain
ducasse et lectrices de versailles saint
quentin
oui j'aime pas dit que deux ont chacune
été toujours éditeurs américains parlant
de la canette est sorti tout à l'heure
florence berck à déstocker vous êtes
avocat au barreau de versailles et
christophe maury directrice et écrivains
notamment l'auteur du plus belle
biographie deux molières dont au fera en
le 400e anniversaire de la naissance
voilà maintenant des deux ans pour leur
vendre comme des petits pains
alors évidemment on est obligé d'en
parler la grève la grève avec
la prise de parole du premier ministre
edouard philippe
on pensait que manger des choses ça les
a plutôt compliqué est ce que vous
comprenez ça ça a compliqué les choses
que la réforme soit si mal engagée
non mais moi je ne trouve pas la réforme
si mal engagée que ça elle est
visiblement mal comprise par l'ensemble
des des français qui me ces français qui
me sidère à chaque fois parce qu'ils ont
les interviewe tous les matins ils sont
tous là en disant je galère comme un
malade dans le train mais je compatis zh
les comprend et sait donc je dire cesser
totalement t'agites c'est un peuple ne
sont respectés victoire sondages qui
montraient que les pros c'était en
majorité favorables à la réforme des
retraites et on va gratter favorables au
mouvement qui étaient contre la réforme
d'un vote soit c'est parce que les
médias sélectionne les gens et que
personne n'a le droit de passer à
l'antenne pour dire je ne soutiens pas
s'agresser mais c'est pas un complot
c'est brigitte martinez ne vous parlera
tout à l'heure j'espère dire de ce
sinistre martinez qui maintenant est en
train de nous dire que le régime des
retraites actuel est bien et qu'il faut
pas le changer alors pendant des années
il était là en train de dire c'est une
catastrophe
mais maintenant ce maintenant c'est bien
faudrait pas changer enfin bon on
s'éloigne du sujet mais non franchement
c'est cette grève n'a plus aucun sens
aucune raison d'être
et puis quand je vois quand on voit en
plus les cégétistes qui sont là à hurler
des injures homophobes au chauffeur de
bus qui veulent
qui ne veulent pas faire la grève on est
au delà de tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
un jeu derrière le volant après fall
communiqué la théorie oui non mais c'est
très elle a fait un communiqué du oui
alors les insultes homophobes c'est pas
terrible mais quand même c'est à cause
du gouvernementaux ne vois pas à quoi en
quoi le gouvernement responsable de deux
dames ont servi du cégétiste de base ça
ça je plante
bah oui enfin c'est ce qu'on entend dire
à l'otan que je pense que là l'été des
assez mal engagée parce qu'elle n'était
pas lisible c'est un peu ce qu'on disait
lors de la dernière émission
et alors là moi j'ai un problème de
compréhension sur l'âge déquilibre
puisque l'âge déquilibre de 64 ans parce
que j'avais cru comprendre dans le
programmes des manuels macron qu'en
réalité on passait complètement sur un
régime à points et donc qu'on ait un âge
à 62 ans avant lequel on puisse pas
prendre sa retraite je veux bien mais
après qu'on nous dise à 64 ans il faut
avoir une retraite à taux plein si on
parle de points voit plus très bien de
qu'on parle parce que soit on dit à 62
ans après vous pouvez prendre votre
retraite et puis on prend la retraite
avec les points que l'on a en fonction
de la valeur du point
tandis que là on nous dit si vous n'avez
pas vos points à 64 ans vos points vont
être si vous prenez votre retraite à 62
sans avoir la retraite à taux plein mais
je comprends pas ce que c'est que la
retraite à taux plein autant je
comprends ce que c'est que la retraite à
taux plein quand on parle de trimestre
autant je ne comprends pas ce que c'est
que la retraite à taux plein quand on a
des points parce que deux points sur la
piste mythique et rire me semble que les
trimestres du point les plombe les
bourses sociales da en fonction de ses
revenus sur de la longueur de 2
sion et les non c'est pas en fonction de
la longueur de visas c'est sûr que c'est
parce que ça me fout les coins vous
gagnez plus vous avez de points oui donc
ça devait être le début avec points donc
le pouvoir dans ce cas là si c'était
pour dégager sa retraite à 45 ans enfin
comme pour les coaches à la carafe d'eau
gratuites chez carrefour avec votre
carte carrefour il faut des points jean
charles jean charles de gaulle si on
gagne beaucoup d'argent on va avoir
beaucoup de points et on va pouvoir
partir très tôt dans ce cas là comment
si on suit votre faim au moins 62 ans
donc je vois pas pourquoi il ya
maintenant un peu moins un peu moins
bien payés qu'à 64 c'est un choix si on
a de l'argent on s'arrête à nancy on en
a pas on s'arrête pile à 64 si on veut
un peu plus de bonus
c'est ce qu'a expliqué le oui non mais
je me sens bien mais je trouve que c'est
assez contradictoire par rapport à la
réforme de base qui était à québec des
points donc c'est vrai que sur l'âge
l'equilibre j'ai du mal contre ça manque
peut-être de clarté mais en tout cas
officiellement confiait je ne suis pas
la seule à batouri comprends pas bien il
ya une chose car tu es si on dit deux
dans tous les pays d'europe
on travaille jusqu'à 65 ans minimum et
et là on nous on est en train de me dire
60 de ces scandaleuses 64 s'est passé ça
va il faudrait que les français
réalisent un peu qu'on est dans un monde
christophe ces questions à l'origine
qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir que je trouve
que tout est extrêmement bien scénarisée
et on est dans quelque chose d'une pièce
de théâtre militaire des théâtres
magnifiquement bien nos créateurs il y a
eu deux ans de concertation
il ya eu une grève par rapport à la
concertation s'était même pas par
rapport à une négociation par rapport à
un texte bon maintenant on a un texte
depuis mercredi le premier ministre et
il faut saluer l'extraordinaire tandem
entre le président de la république et
le premier ministre parce que c'est très
huilé
ce n'est pas comme du temps de retard
mitterrand ou
e2 juppé chirac là on sent que de la
raison de rôles de souligner ça parce
que ce n est que si me terreur va
laisser faire ça réformera au cas on
n'en serait pas là aujourd'hui je le
pense aussi
mais là on arrête tandem qui a
remarquablement bien eu coordonnées
ensuite on en arrive maintenant dans une
période de négociation attention ça va
être présenté au conseil des ministres
en janvier donc là il va falloir se
bousculent et si on veut changer les
choses et ensuite il y aura les
amendements à l'assemblée nationale au
mois de juin
donc là il faudra travailler au corps
les députés pour savoir si on bon pour
le moment le truc est très bien écrit
c'est à dire qu'il faut sortir de la
crise pour sortir de la crise il faut
que ça soit un win win d' il faut que
chacun y retrouve ses petits
laurent berger hurle en disant 64 ans on
avait dit qu'on donnait pas sachez que
voilà on venait pas parlé mais bien
évidemment la main tendue c'est de çà va
être aux alentours du 20 décembre juste
avant noël au moment des congés
scolaires ou là le premier ministre va
dire 64 on n'en parle plus puisque comme
vous venez de dire je paye vaud 63 ans
il parlera plus de ce niveau on va
revenir sur cette idée de points là
uniquement de points et on va revenir
sur l'esprit de e 2 est ce que c est
vieux textes padres que le sénat où ses
bienfaits parce que j'ai demandé
d'écrire le script regardé comme si bien
fait cette semaine on a eu au ministère
de l'intérieur en une nuit une
négociation qui s'est fait et les
policiers et gardes d'honneur c'est
l'oeuf le régime spécial qui éclairait
que même pour ceux qui sont dans les
bureaux
ce qui est une bonne chose parce que ça
peut permettre de la mobilité au sein
même d'une profession maintenant
qu'est-ce qui se passe le premier
ministre a donné un cadre laurent berger
n'est pas d'accord pour l'âge pivot
on va là on va l'abandonner et ensuite
ministère par ministère
vous allez avoir des négociations qui
vont chaque comme il ya eu au ministère
de et avec vous de l'intérieur et tout
le monde va sortir grandi de cette
histoire sauf ou votre avis martin est
ce votre famille martinez mesut façon le
combat sophie gagne pas ce nom mais le
rien est rien n'est joué encore plus
combat il perdu patrice puisque la loi
de la sncf et de la modernisation de la
sncf a été votée l'an dernier
bon et que c'est cette dynamique là qui
va faire que les changements sur la
question donc c'est le combat de ces le
combat de trop pour monsieur martinez
mais regardez comme c'est très très bien
écrits peuvent par le gouvernement pour
que tout le monde sorte grandie de cette
non pas confrontation mais de ce
dialogue est encore une fois mais je dis
chapeau et je lève encore mon chapeau
sur l'intervention du premier ministre
qui a parlé d'une retraite minimale à
1000 euros
et moi je dis mais bravo notre pays quoi
bravo notre pays qui à cette générosité
et qui donne un socle je trouve ça
formidable
alors ensuite c'était intelligent et
vous n'avez pas peur de l'intelligence
non moi je trouve que tout est parfait
c'est ok peut-être à tort cette annonce
vient d'une visite dans la confiance ils
t'ont la confiance notamment acquérir la
confiance à l'attention des gens les
autorités ont détruit quand ça marche
pas toujours
c'est à manseau je crois aussi à ce
scénario
c'est bien plus subtil qu'on ne le pense
et ça semble assez assez bien écrit jeu
je trouve que globalement sans entrer
dans les détails techniques qui pour
beaucoup d'entre eux échappent pour
l'instant que a priori moi je suis
plutôt en effet satisfaits de voir des
catégories de 2,2
j'allais dire de travailleurs c'est fini
de salariés qui vont pouvoir bénéficier
d'un système bien plus juste je pense
notamment aux agriculteurs aux ouvriers
agricoles à tous et aux femmes à toutes
catégories de population qui jusqu'à
présent étaient globalement plus ou
moins exclu
deneault de nos mécanismes de retraite
il ya une deuxième chose à laquelle je
crois beaucoup
c est en cela je ne soutiens pas le
mouvement de grève c'est que le service
public ça se respecte
quand on assurer une mission de service
public c'est globalement un honneur
c'était de cette manière là en tout cas
que je le conçois que ce soit pour
conduire un train ou pour enseigner dans
un amphithéâtre où kwakwa fin voilà vous
regardez multiples tâches que cela
implique on respecte sa mission respecte
le service public le droit de grève est
un droit constitutionnel mais il doit
être concilier avec d'autres droits
fondamentaux et d'autres valeurs
ce qui me semble-t-il n'est pas
nécessairement toujours le cas et puis
enfin moi je pour ce qui me concerne
vraiment ce qui concerne ma petite
personne moi j'aspire plus tôt et si
j'en ai la chance à pouvoir travailler
plus longtemps
je suis alors peut-être que pardon
excusez moi je vous interromps surnommé
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de l'égalité
de est ce que c est ce que c'est beau
critères moi je me semble que on
pourrait regarder des régimes spéciaux
il ya peut-être qu'ils sont quand
justifiant pas justifiable et puis on
pourrait regarder au fond des sous et
des oraisons il ya des professions vous
exercez une profession intellectuelle
dans lesquelles bob de jongh pas
forcément 8,7 à 62 ans parfois très
physique faire un cours en rie théâtre
sébire est pas cher et qu'on bouna
traoré 15 marteau piqueur ces jeunes
j'ai la chance de ne pas pousser un
wagonnet au fond d'une mine ray
je remarque j'étais dans une soutenance
de thèse hier j'avais celui qui fut mon
directeur de thèse il ya 24 ans qui a 71
ans et j'ai été ébloui par sa
démonstration par sa verdeur par sa
jeunesse et je me suis dit oh moi même
c'est pas la première fois qu'elle
dommages à 65 ans couperet ça c'est
extrêmement donnant des petits jeunes
qui sont bien formules sont intelligents
qui ont le moule de de l'époque et qui
doivent enseigner assez vite
ça n'empêche pas il faut pas mais on
parlera tout à l'heure de peut-être des
personnes âgées est ce qu'on pourrait
utiliser oui jeune homme mais c'est de
l'esa encore votre cas est mise à mort
dans les perdants nous on a donc en tant
qu'avocat on a un régime autonome qui
est pas un régime spécial puisque on est
soumis à l'âge légal mais nous notre
retraite de base puisque on a un système
aussi collectives de solidarité et à
1400 euros
donc ça veut dire que lorsqu'on va
appliquer ce canton va nous le dire
exactement
il s'agit de l'as quel que soit le
système à points qui le système de la
jcch daric et l'arrco marche plutôt bien
et les syndicats dire qu'ils en sont les
gestionnaires le reconnaissent et pour
toi s'oppose à ce régime a pointé aussi
encore là une contradiction
la cgt a été très favorable au système à
points bêtement pendant plusieurs
décennies absolument et je reprends ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure justement
ce que j'avais il y avait un édito de
giesbert qui disait au fond peut-être
que la tragédie s'est nouée quand le
gouvernement a eu la fâcheuse idée
d'introduire de l'équité de la justice
sociale dans la réforme
en intégrant les petits des oubliés
comme les femmes les ouvriers agricoles
métiers pénibles etc
c'est un peu ce que buzz que vous disiez
et c'est vrai que c'est des gens qui
sont pas défendus par les syndicats
et ça pose vraiment ce problème
d'acquérir des savoirs qui défend qui
défendent des syndicats les syndicats ce
très corporatistes aussi donc il défend
et c'est fou la ratp et des lissiers
parce que c'est un peu idiot par le
privé défier ces gens c'est une question
la france est quand même mais quasiment
bloqué par des cheminots et des
conducteurs de bus parisiens et de métro
enfin je veux dire c'est ahurissant
comme on a l'impression que là et que la
france et pointe des retraites ne se ne
pourrait se résumer qu'à ces deux
groupes de salariés qui sont qui n'ont
pas de soucis majeurs par rapport un
agriculteur par rapport à un commerçant
qui voit son commerce absolument vide et
où les jours parce que personne ne peut
accéder jusqu'à l'iae eux sont vraiment
dans l'embarras effectivement que comme
le disent très très souvent les
grévistes bon on a mis notre treizième
mois de côté puis toute façon plus ça va
aller et puis et puis on verra
c'est sûr que faire la grève à la sncf
c'est beaucoup plus facile que de la
faire quand on est exploitant agricole
commerçants restaurateurs et c'est ce
qu'on oublie un tout petit peu toujours
dans les commentaires des hommes c'est
merveilleux qui bien que la france
globalement que les gens soutiennent ces
greffes et réalise le rêve pourrait
peut-être après tout pourrait le
comprendre de dire d'aller de tirer
plutôt vers le haut ou vers le bas
c'est dire que les réformes dont
toujours une situation plus difficile
qu'elle celle qu'elle était avant
après tout on pourrait rêver que tout
tous les tout le monde puisse prendre sa
retraite à 52 non celle entre l'internât
le pivot qui choque un peu florence
devant disparaître de 64 ans et 52 ans
yaka
mais ensuite il n'ya pas les gens
donnent à fond mais moi ça me choque
terriblement que les gens prennent leur
retraite à 52 ans et surtout dans un
régime qui est déficitaire qui coûtent
des milliards qui nous coûtent des
millions je voulais dire à chaque fois
qu'un cheminot prend sa retraite ou un
type de la ratp prend sa retraite à 52
53 54 55 ans c'est moi qui les paient
que sa retraite mais du coup je sais pas
comment ils traitent les carrières
longues
est ce que quand on est en carrière
longue qu'on arrive à 62 ans et d'anti
maintiennent ce qu'on ne croit pas mais
s'ils maintiennent l'âge des climats 64
ans est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir partir ou
pas soit c'est je pense que ce qui rend
le départ je ne sais pas s'il ya autant
ce ne sont que des cas particuliers
alors ce qui rend le débat anxiogène
c'est qu'on se pose la question pour soi
même en disant comment ça va hors la loi
c'est un cadre et ensuite ça va être
entre les entreprises les ministères et
que on va pouvoir ticks vous allez voir
des rachats on lui pose la question
comment ça se passe pour moi
bon mais c'est pas maintenant autour de
cette table ni sur tous les débats que
l'on voit ou que l'on entend à la
télévision et à la radio où on voit que
on ne fait que de tricoter des petits
cas particulier et ses sincères en tout
donc sauf dans les cartons dans un grand
mouvement de justice sociale qui est ce
ce changement de 2,2 de calcul ch cette
nouvelle loi de la retraite
emmanuel macron l'avait promis dans dans
la campagne présidentielle
ça fait deux ans qu'ils y travaillent ça
arrive
réjouissons nous bravons il tient ses
promesses qu'il l'ait fait bravo et
encore une fois la sncf ne sort pas
grandi de cette histoire parce qu'ils
ont déjà la réforme qui était passé et
on va voir ce que ça va donner avec la
concurrence dans quelques années mais là
c'est le c'est la loi du marché qui va
malheureusement baleiniers mais janvier
1er janvier
vous avez vu la une du point non alors
là une des boîtes de bonbons halal ce
pays est il devenu fou
voilà la réponse est oui comme ces
subtiles et mesurée ç'a toujours été une
phrase de l'historien michel vidéo qui
disait d'histoire de la france est celle
d'une guerre civile tantôt vives et
semblant tantôt l'arrêt mais prête
toujours prête à renaître d'accord avec
cette analyse
c'est plutôt optimiste alors toujours
prête à renoncer
oui mais il ya peut-être une renaissance
à chaque fois mais je perds civil non
non écouter enfin il suffit de regarder
un autre un peu plus métal notamment on
est on est là dans une mutation
tellement profonde et puis qui se
réalise sur des sur des décennies
au fond c'est page non non je crois pas
qu'on soit un peuple guerrier gaulois
tout dit on et pour que je me fasse j'y
crois un peuple un peu fou parce que ce
qui est incompréhensible c'est que dès
que quelqu'un est élu un président il
est détesté au bout de dix mois les
français détestent macron ils ont
détesté olemps ils ont détesté sarkozy
il déteste tout le monde mise alors que
gérard nommé ça mais voilà maintenant
qui dément est passé de danseuse amateur
souvent les gens qui n'ont rien fait ben
voilà mais donc c'est quand même un peu
déprimant c'est juste c'est dire que la
5ème république c'est une monarchie dans
laquelle on coupe la tête du roi tous
les hommes préfèrent donc ça n'incite
pas à la réforme et se trouve
franchement le président mâcon courageux
et edouard philippe
très justement puisqu'on parlait de
walkman d'ivoire philippe open ferme
voire institut ce même si on peut dire
est ce que il y alliez des sondages qui
marque qui montre qu'edouard philippe
peut finalement un bouclier assez solide
d'emmanuel macro rôle que le quinquennat
avait avril à peu diluées
oui c'est la bourse oui oui hélas là
c'est très enfin c'est très singulier
quand même comme si comme retournement
de situation le présent la république
avec le quinquennat est beaucoup plus
exposés pourquoi parce qu'il a une
majorité parlementaire qui est
concordantes chronologiquement avec son
élection
donc il n'ya pas de suspense il ya plus
de suspense dans cette dans cette
concordance pour éviter les
cohabitations et le rôle institutionnel
en effet du premier ministre telles que
la vème république l'a conçu c'est
d'être soi un bouclier soit un fusible
quand ça sedan ça se passe mal
collaborateurs alors voir un
collaborateur mais justement à l'époque
de sarkozy fillon
on a vu dans appartient la première
moitié du quinquennat fillon acquérir
une popularité assez forte
assez exceptionnel d'avoir un premier
ministre au détriment de nicolas sarkozy
au point où se demander parfois qu'elle
est elle qui était le bouclier de
l'autre et là la logique de la vème
république retombe sur ses pieds si je
veux dire avec un président qui préside
et un premier ministre qui maquille
eto'o qui est touchant oui le président
de la république ce n'est pas intervenue
les voleurs institutionnellement résolu
est dans son rôle vous avez
m poutine enfin il est surtout il est
sur tous les fronts
mais là le calendrier est très très bien
écrit c'est à dire que vous avez vous
pensez qu'il ya comme ça des ex machina
qui écrit tout ça c'est que la plus
relevée non mais je pense que je pense
que nous avons affaire à des gens
extrêmement responsables et qu'ils ont
parfaitement travaillé leurs affaires et
ses passions passionnant éviter
l'improvisation est donc d'abord dans le
dans le calendrier
le calendrier présidentiel il est sur
l'international il se montre très
fortement à l'international en ce moment
même et puis le premier ministre et est
sur le front de l'intérieur et est très
présent non c'est très très bien fait
moi je suis pas ce que ça veut dire que
c'est décidé
ça veut dire que c'est s'est préparé
décidé pour que les choses avancent et
on inverse des gens intelligents
responsables c'est une vision optimiste
de la situation mais les gens
travaillent et sont responsables mais
c'est vrai que pardon je reviens je
reviens au débat sur premier vice
président de la république
on a l'impression et il ya longtemps de
mépris cette impression là qui a une
répartition des rôles
voyez il sait pas quand valls était
premier ministre on avait juste et
l'impression qu'ils voulaient prendre la
place de l'autre il sait ce qu'il ya
souveraineté le crâne
fillon l'a pas fait pendant pendant cinq
ans mais mais là on a bien compris il
voulait la place de président république
après là on al'impression voilà qui se
répartissent assez bien les rôles et que
le et le premier me prends les choses en
charge quoi on a même en nous et ça a un
côté pour revenir à ce dont nous
parlions sur les gens âgés enfin c'est
une pratique un peu vintage de la
semaine du handicap mais qui correspond
vraiment à l'esprit des institutions
alors il ya il ya peut-être une nuance
apportée à ce
ce propos c'est c'est que le fond il n'y
a qu'une seule parole qui coûte quand
même en france c'est celle du prison les
conti par le bas ça ne vaut rien quoi
mais il y là le président de la
république et c'était d'ailleurs dans
l'intention du candidat emmanuel macron
c'était de moins intervenir de mon
travail
oui on fait vite r oui jupitérien ça a
été mal compris mais leur jupitérien
c'est pas c'est pas le type qui est
partout qui fait ou non qui est demandée
contre la personne qui prend du recul le
plus le deus avec avec la pratique
sarkozy hollande et en cela il était
très conforme à une lecture gaullienne
je ne dis pas gaulliste mais gaullienne
la vème république qu on apprécie ou pas
là n'est pas la question mais en effet
le grand débat etc
on a vu un président de la république en
chemise manches retourner et prendre le
micro et s'emparer et porter comme ça
quand le grand débat oui les dés sont là
il est franchement de l'homme il est
franchement détendu comme aucun autre
président de la république ne l'avait
fait retard d'affronter mal à fond ses
citoyens ni les contestations ça c'est
en effet par défaut qu'on peut lui
reconnaître
on verra donc les dans les prochains jo
c'est d'optimisme de christophe maury
l'emportent franchement alors on va
peut-être passer au débat sur la mise en
examen la mise en examen des hommes
politiques est ce qu'elle doit entraîner
selon la jurisprudence balladur la
démission des fonctions qu'on exerce tel
débat
[Musique]
[Rires]
voilà donc mise en examen notamment de
françois bayrou paul et pour les
affaires du modem et du monde
oui mais qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce que
vous pensez
je pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui je
rappelle ce que la jurisprudence
balladur qui était de dire qu alors ça
concernait les ministres mais quant à
mehdi ce raid mise en examen il doit
démissionner et on l'a vu pour un
certain nombre de ministres on l'a vu
notamment après pour bernard tapie qui
revenait au gouvernement une fois
qu'elle était blanchie
alors je me suis alors peut-être
psychorigide sur le plan du droit mais
il ya une présomption d'innocence et une
mise en examen veut pas dire que c'est
une condamnation
bon c'est un peu dans l'esprit des
personnes si il est mis en examen n'a
pas de fumée sans feu donc probablement
qui sera condamné donc un présomption
d'innocence qui me paraît tout à fait
respectable et je pense qu'il ne faut
pas démissionner immédiatement sécurisé
enfin la question est plus politique en
réserve véridiquement gerengbo elle
n'était pas capable
m votre raisonnement de faim était
absolument en béton nous sommes un oui
nous ne sommes pas étonnés mais
politiquement c'était le cas c'est
moralement et moralement aussi c'est
délicat
[Musique]
moralement mais justement est ce que
c'est de la morale ou est-ce que c'est
du droit
c'est pas la morale est forte mais
pourvu que ça dure
sauf que politiquement est ce que cette
nabeul saleh saleh sans doute de moins
en moins qu'un ministre en exercice soit
mis en examen on peut dire ce qu'on veut
mais politiquement il n'y a pas de fumée
sans feu qui soit et il ya même un
exemple dans lesquelles un ministre en
exercice mis en examen obligé de
démissionner déficit un an ou un an et
demi plus tard demain je suis par
exemple strauss kahn et elle seule c'est
pareil
oui en effet un an un an et demi plus
tard ben on en parle plus et on oublie
et mais c'est compliqué de revenir
c'est effectivement très clair les cas
précédents le redis sur le point de vue
de la morale et de la loi l'a quand même
une chose qui peut peut-être faire
bouger les lignes c'est mélenchon
mélenchon qui lui a été condamné et qui
a encore deux ans réclamé que aucun
qu'une personne ne puisse se présenter à
la moindre élection appartement où il
avait été condamné à quelque chose
j'attends donc de voir si moralement
mais aussi politique vous concerne
évidemment et diabolique donc j'attends
juste de voir si mélenchon va renommer
est-ce que c'est pas donné à la justice
alors le fait de l'aide mais avait cette
jurisprudence balladur me dire la
démission la démission magath wars c'est
donner à la justice un pouvoir énorme
quand même sur le fonctionnement
politique mais c'est souvent le cas le
pouvoir puisque c'est une question aussi
politique le pouvoir politique il
appartient au souverain c'est à dire aux
électeurs le peuple bon mais c'est le
peuple sous certains aspects
cette expression a été employé à tort et
à travers on sait pas en réalité ce que
c'est que le peuple les électeurs je
sais ce que c'est le souverain dessine
l'anssi politiquement c'est gênant je ne
parle pas de la morale parce que il joue
je crois qu'il faut laisser la morale
en dehors de tout cela mais
politiquement si c'est gênant à ya des
sanctions qui existe il ya un système
démocratique électorale qui permet aux
gens avec un bulletin de vote de
sanctionner un élu qui à leurs yeux
n'aurait pas respecté je vois la justice
a tout pouvoir la justice a fait juste
son rôle des signes l'addition de
pouvoir que qu'est la côte elle prend
une décision c'est son pouvoir mais ça
lui donne une influence sur le
déroulement politique qui est quand même
100 litres c'est les hommes politiques
qui ont donné une influence politique à
la justice c'est eux qui disent ah bah
oui mais ça ça des effets politiques
c'est une justice médiatique jean paul
delevoye a reconnu va penser à
démissionner justement puisqu'on vient
de s'apercevoir qu'il avait quitté le
pays ces cinq jours s'annonce à
l'assurance était bénévole
mais qui dit touché également 1000 5000
euros par mois je me suis avec elle
organise ce qui paraît était absolument
c'est entré à la constitution et on a
pas moins d'être donc là si c'est
vraiment content à la constitution
l'association anticor froid qui portent
plainte fait qu'ils veulent et qui du
coup il pourrait être mis en examen il a
pensé lui avant d'être mis en examen
démissionner
finalement la particularité c'est qu'il
touche et a effectivement de l'argent
mais il s'est pris d'assurance
il était lié à ces axa je me souviens
plus en fait il est lié à une compagnie
d'assurance et camille fait cette
réforme
oui dans lequel va y avoir probablement
des assurances complémentaires il y
avait quand même dit oui ça c'est le
niveau bénévoles mais une affirmation ça
me suis sentie à payer 5000 euros par
une autre
un think tank et il ne l'avait pas
déclaré a déclaré ce qui est quand même
un peu étrange parce qu'il avait
d'autres choses notamment qu'il était
membre de deux de la confrérie des
amateurs de vins de sympa mais ça ils
avaient oublié bizarrement ce qui est
quand même ça ça donne une image curieux
ce cadre elle d'oublier qu'on à 5300
veille c'est d'après moi c'est comme la
garde des sceaux public et la vanne
appartements et rubis en avait j'en ai 3
pour ceux qui ont avec deux parce que
c'est là on est revenu au sol et voilà
on peut pas toujours complimenté le
pouvoir que le devoir de précaution
rentrer dans les questions morales et je
l'en cette provocation
il est bien évident que lorsque
quelqu'un est nommé il y a d'abord des
commissions il ya d'abord des
déclarations que ce soit pour une
élection pour une place dans un
ministère même dans l'administration la
grande administration
il ya quand même des enquêtes qui sont
faites alors moi je ne comprends pas il
faut attendre que le texte de la loi de
la retraite tombent eux sur les écrans
pour que je sais plus quel média attaque
delevoye ça fait juste deux ans le
parisien ça fait juste sortie la wii
mais alors ça tombe ça tombe à point
nommé
enfin ce qu'ils ont fait c'est pas les
revoir des gens d'abord au commissaire à
la retraite depuis moins de six mois et
donc pas non plus et puis voilà c'est
qu'il est normal que quand on est sous
les feux de la rampe légende années
s'intéresse à la personnalité
alors qui a failli est ce que c'est la
personne qui a oublié qui a omis ou est
ce que ce sont les instances de qui
doivent régler tout ça qui n'ont pas
fait leur boulot et 2 alors
attaquer ceux qui n'ont pas fait leur
boulot aussi ce proverbe des salons vip
a contraint kratos quand on grimpe aux
arbres il vaut mieux avoir une derrière
propre jeunesse la veille ou cocotiers
qui est vrai c'est que ces autographes
aux cocotiers voilà c'est ça il faut
avoir le bipe propres ah ben on va
passer de t'être à madame mademoiselle
tune berg et ça va être ce mettre la
polémique
[Musique]
alors bonne vous êtes une belle donc
cette jeune femme qui a quel âge 16 en
saison écrit la cre état de son prénom
avec un seul t es et donc qui est devenu
l'icône de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique l'icône de la
lutte pour un monde plus écologiste et
qui est nommée femme de l'année ce qui
n'est pas rien par le times est
généralement des choix très fort oui oui
enfin pas toujours la rue attendant
j'aimerais d'abord vous n'auriez pas
nommée femme de l'année en cours
stéphane n'ont évidemment non non et
s'offrent c'est nouveau c'est
intéressant il faut y réfléchir
klaus et 3 d'eau alors commençons par
les noms alors pour quelles raisons pour
quelle raison parce que les curieux
cette cette jeune fille alors d'abord
elle a 16 ans donc il n'y absolument
rien contre les gens qui ont 16 ans tout
à fait avoir des choses passionnantes à
dire est que je souviens d'un roi des
rois de suède qui a 15 ans abattu
à la tête de son armée une armée de 600
mille hommes donc il ya quinze ans on
peut faire des choses très brillant
white six ans déjà mais non c'est pas du
tout les gens dont c'est absolument
avéré nommé de 600 mille hommes arrêtés
style des exercices dans les combats
quand même un droit dessus alors greta
est là elle a 16 ans qu'est ce qu'elle
dit elle répète de façon assez horrible
et ce que ses parents lui ont
visiblement mis dans la tête
quels experts de haut niveau dit à 16
ans on peut dire des choses et en même
temps assez au point de faire que
répéter ce que 19 mai et on voit qu'on
voit pas trop quelle est sa réflexion je
veux dire le fait de crier de l'uruguay
quelle est sa réaction c'est de dire
qu'il ya urgence c'est une mobilisation
contre une photo les récents n'a rien
annoncé mais le but c'est une
responsabilité c'est de déprimer tout le
monde mais il n'y a rien fait bouger
mais nommer ce qui est totalement
déprimant c'est que les jeunes
visiblement voilà ce que les attaques de
fond se prennent cette personne comme
référence
on est en france on est dans un pays où
il ya des experts absolument brillant il
ya des scientifiques ya des tonnes de
gens étaient quasi nulles intelligemment
et nous quels sont les deux icônes que
les jeunes se choisissent en france
great attenberg et nicolas hulot alors
excusez moi mais on est quand même au
degré zéro de la science et du savoir
c'est déprimant mais c'est totalement
des princes il ya aucune expertise ne
peut même pas discuter avec eux et leur
en plus on n'a pas le droit de dire du
mal de cette jeune femme
ce qu'il faut pas dire jeune fille il
faut plus dire demoiselle vous signale
toute personne du sexe féminin doit être
appelée madame a maintenant donc le mot
demoiselle est supprimée de la wii
[Musique]
langage ya plus de mal donc on a mis son
internat mis son autisme en avant et
comme son autisme et mis en avant du
coup c'est une sorte de paravent qui
fait que dès qu'on critique quand on a
tellement l'habitude ici vous êtes
méchant ogre et attenberg est autiste
mais dd otis brillant et puis
désertiques sont moins brillants et je
veux dire c'est pas moi qui étais
qu'emile le doigt sur son actif ses
parents qui en font une sorte de
paravent publicitaires de ses parents
ses fans source est votre analyse si
vous êtes plutôt qu'autre mais oui non
c'est pas pour les bonnes raisons
c'est presque je trouve que dans le peu
d'analystes qu'elle produit parce
qu'elle est surtout dans l'indignation
pour l'indignation ça marche à un moment
mais dans un second temps il faut il
faut agir de manière de manière
raisonnée il faut avancer et c'est pas
en s'indignant que nous sommes on fait
avancer les choses
il ya eu quelques quelques dérapages
dans les quelques petite analyse qu'elle
quel produit il ya quinze jours ou trois
semaines ou admet la catastrophe
climatique sur le dos du patriarcat et
de je ne sais plus quoi de la lutte des
classes et c'est une psychologue et du
colonialisme la sauce aux sons j'allais
dire son discours qui n'en est pas un
que tu une espèce d'indignation parfois
un peu méchante
d'ailleurs là de mon point de vue
déraper perd en crédibilité et dans la
catégorie des femmes de l'année si tant
est que cela ait un sens je crois que la
communauté scientifique mondiale y
compris françaises y compris dans
l'université à laquelle j'appartiens il
ya voilà il ya du monde je pense alors
qu'il n'est pas une femme mais à jean
jouzel que j'ai eu le bonheur de côtoyer
pendant des années ou à valérie masson
delmotte qui s'offrit nobel de deux des
grands prix nobel d'économie enfin je
vois là il y avait il y avait il y avait
de quoi
sûrement alors ça a là un côté hélas un
peu un peu un peu tête de gondole quoi
si vous voulez et puis n'oublions pas
aussi que le times avait déclaré il ya
trois ou quatre ans que la personnalité
féminine de l'année c'était christine de
christine and the queen
alors votre chat ça nivelle un petit peu
pas être est ce que c'est vraiment la
personnalité emblématique qu'elle a
vraiment à pouvoir ce que great in the
queen a vraiment peur
la chanteuse de l'année peut-être sommes
parfaitement d'accord sur le fond avec
stéphane
sur l'absence de disque à l'absence de
construction d'un discours après son
indignation
la seule chose c'est que son indignation
si elle réveille un peu les états pour
qu'ils avancent mais enfin bon je suis
pas convaincu
mais non je suis pas je pense que
c'était pas c'est pas la femme de
l'année et il y avait comme stéphane le
disent et plein d'autres personnes et
dans ce domaine là pouvoir être là la
personnalité ou la femme de l'année sur
ce terrain-là a les défauts et alors
attention faut pas dire autistes veut
dire asperger les asperger ne considère
pas qu'ils sont dans la catégorie des
autistes défense je suis emballé par ce
choix parce que ce n'est pas une
personne c'est un élan c'est une
jeunesse c'est une icône et vous parliez
de tête de gondole oui mais la grève du
vendredi en disant à tous les jeunes
on ne va plus en place le vendredi parce
que il faut manifester c'est c'est un
truc de jeunes au niveau de
connaissances phénomène
alors ne demandez pas ne demandez pas à
la petite greta de faire des analyses
bon ce qu'elle dit elle a assimilé mal
assimilé analysé pas d'analyser ces
pannes scientifique
c'est un élan c'est un élan
international d'une jeunesse qui dit on
veut maintenant faire attention à notre
planète
vous avez certainement vous gé chez nous
mais aussi les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent
on a tous des greta à la maison qui nous
disent mais ne met pas le plastique là
ils ont 14 ans ils ont 15 ans et c'est
eux qui sont très vigilants aujourd'hui
et je trouve ça très bien que le greta
soit de droite attenberg soit la femme
de l'année parce que c'est la jeunesse
de l'année et c'est de dire maintenant
ce sont les enfants les jeunes qui vont
être vigilant par rapport à ce que nous
nous faisons déjà à la maison mais
ensuite au niveau industriel national
international et sert donc je trouve que
c'est très bien parce que ça donne de
l'espoir et que c'est la jeunesse qui
prend les choses en main et
regrettant que vous avez chez vous qui
vous interdit d'acheter des couverts en
plastique
c'est très bien à cette greta là qui va
pour des questions d'image traverser
l'atlantique en bateau et oui soyez ces
six tickets d'années et on peut déjà
penser bien qu'en disant cela on va dire
oui je ne suis qu un immonde mâles
blancs de plus 56 ans et 19 ans j'aime
bien la voici ce que je me demande si
dans ceux qui s'opposent à cette a7
greta tonnes belle il n'ya pas quand
même beaucoup de climato sceptiques
pas du tout vous regardez la liste des
gens qui s'y opposent s'est pas désuni
solutions qui sont mes très très bon
vous avez vu je vais milieu d'été à
l'été dernier c'est une tête à claques
nous attend c'est un symbole c'est pas l
état semble être un formidable effet des
baisses s'emparent de ce combat enfin
après la jeunesse sans perdre ce combat
ils sont tous en train de défiler pour
sauver pour sauver climat pourra pour
nous mettre en avant la décroissance etc
ils sont tous en basket qui viennent de
chine et qui coûtent moins de 150 euros
à chaque pied alors qu'ils commencent
aussi à regarder un petit peu comme moi
ils vivent dans les défilés en basque
est fabriqué en chine pour sauver le
climat
il ya comme une aberration
mieux je trouve ce qui est plus choquant
c'est la grève du vendredi la grève de
l'entraînement quand même des millions
de jeunes
il rêverait de pouvoir aller au lycée ou
à l'école ou au moins un jour par
semaine
oui c'est assez d'accord avec vous bon
ben on vous raconte il n'y aura pas
assumer la ja sunny adé il ya des noms
qui sont presque des wii et saufs sur
suite au désistement
je voulais juste mot justement la saison
vous disiez et audi il y avait un
article du parisien et un rapport d'une
députée stop au racisme motive us qui
est un racisme anti vieux assez
d'éclairage du jour là une députée qui
s'appelle audrey du feu joubert vient de
remettre un rapport pour lutter contre
eux ce qu'on appelle l'âgisme et contre
les ok boomer donné ok boomer ce sont
ceux à qui comme greta ken feinberg
les jeunes disent ouais mais tu es
devant toi avec ton âge tu peut plus
comprendre mais a été dépassé
moi je dîne inverse selon qu' on ne
réfléchit plus honni lucio sur de
l'affect sur deux sur deux de la
réaction épidermique alors des greta on
les aime ou on aime pas sans dire
pourquoi on aime ou sur une sans dire
pourquoi on aime pas donc les jeunes ils
sont là et dès qu'on propose une
réflexion les jeunes certains je ne veux
pas du tout la bd est certaine sans
leurs baillis même et vous discutez vous
êtes un vieux combat oui oui si on
essaye d'argumenter si on a fait preuve
d'un tout petit peu de réflexion
d'intelligence et de culture
on passe pour un abruti c'est vrai mes
souvenirs je revendique le droit est un
abruti dans ce cas là parce que je veux
dire moi j'aime bien discuter c'est bien
avoir des arguments et c'est pour ça
genre lorsque j'ai tout à l'heure je
préfère des scientifiques a great
attenberg et je le jure je revendique le
fait d'être un hoquet boomers
non mais il ya cette idée quand même que
à certains trappe
avec l'âge on est un peu en dehors de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui on peut chasser
ses vieux comme le monde ça pour le coup
la jeunesse en soi n'est pas une vertu
dont donc voix c'est avec ce je crois
que c'est cohn bendit qui répondait ça
mais cohn bendit version version 2000
2000 et plus
oui c'est avec des pays qui ont fait des
vieux cons il ya des gens bien et pas
bien partout cette scission entre les
jeunes les jeunes je sais pas je sais
pas si je ne sais pas qui ils sont et
les vieux pareil moi je ne sais pas on
peut être on peut être vieux très jeune
je ça ça ce truc là c'était très vieux
jeu les jeux je travaillais il ya
quelques quelques temps sur les
institutions athénienne il y avait une
institution est l'ancêtre des senna
senna ça vient d'eux du mot vieillesse
adil sénile et qui s'appelle la guerre
aux ja et donc il y avait un conseil de
gens âgés et les gens âgés et lé l'île
des dieux
parce que il parvenait à atteindre un
âge assez important c'était donc le
signe de quelque chose et cette supposée
sagesse agacé en réalité tout le monde
c'était les plus jeunes qui vociféraient
écrivait dépend flex déjà long oui et
alors c'est un truc et mais constant
récurrents réalité est donc ce truc
ok boomers et refermer là parce que tu
comprends rien parce que tu es vieux ben
je sais je serai pas là pour le voir
mais on verra dans 50 ans il y aura
autre chose et puis c'est x ce qui est
amusant c'est qu'on est dans un pays qui
vit est-ce que c'est avec lui mais les
vieux dérange et je joue ils ont on a
toujours navigué entre le la personne
d'un certain âge enfin disons le vieux
incarnation d'une forme de sagesse est
rien
cette saison verra et puis le vieux qui
dérange parce que il n'est pas loin de
la mort et que la mort on en a toujours
eu la trouille nos morneau les a à c est
là qu est bien en dehors des villes on
lui déposé dans son tombeau des vivres
des meubles etc pour qu'il soit très
bien dans l'au delà et qui reviennent
pas nous embêter
en résumé enfin je caricature mais c'est
pas ça aujourd'hui la mort on la cache
les vieux on les met dans des ehpad faut
pas trop les sortir mais il n'ya là rien
rien que de très nouveau enfin tout cela
tout cela qu'il faut rapport là dessus
ou pas c'est une structure familiale a
explosé c'est à dire que ça c'est vrai
oui c'est à dire que le vieux avait sa
place dans la structure familiale il
allait devenir l'eau sage ce grand-père
la personne dont on s'occupait et la
fragilité n'était pas n'était pas un
délit vous me direz ces phases un
handicap n'était pas une tare or
aujourd'hui le vieux il doit se
débrouiller tout seul parce que il est
sourd parce qu'il a écouté son walkman
beaucoup trop fort et est aujourd'hui le
vieux est devenu un encombrant donc un
déchet et le vieux c'est celui de
l'ehpad
mais c'est celui juste avant que les
brèdes à ski au 55e dropt agir très
grand âge irene alors que l'âge est de
55 à 60 euros
envoyez un cv dans des entreprises pour
trouver un emploi salarié
c'est un show revient au problème de la
de vaud des patients à la retraite
saisies à bord des eaux gens travailler
plus longtemps mais il fait de plus en
plus de gens qui à 55 ans 50 ce qui me
plaît c'est le vrai problème
et par conséquent il y avait une
structure familiale qui donnait la place
aux vieux
je pense que les drh devrait faire une
réflexion sur une dans l'entreprise la
structure de l'entreprise quelle est la
place et la badr et les plus âgés il est
bien évident que dans la mobilité
on encourage tous les jeunes dans la
mobilité professionnelle
il faut encourager les les responsables
et des rh à favoriser une mobilité
professionnelle pour les seniors pour
qu'ils trouvent un emploi ou leur
expérience leur réseau et leur sagesse
vont être création de valeur pour
l'entreprise mais ça c'est une réflexion
que je n'ai pas encore vu dans les
entreprises de capital il ya eu oui il
ya eu une époque où les grandes
entreprises devaient négocier des
accords qui étaient d accord seniors
oui justement pour pouvoir accompagner
exactement ce que vous dites
pour pouvoir accompagner les personnes
les plus âgées dans le cadre de ses
sorties en tout cas d accompagner en fin
de carrière et pas les laisser sur le
trottoir en les licenciant donc il y a
simplement ça être dès supprimés
c'est pour ça qu'on n'entend plus parler
donc il ya plus par qui pour ça a été ça
a été supprimée me semble-t-il dans le
top c'est dans le d'entrée de la
présidence
hollande où il n'y a plus eu d'accord
seniors ce qui est quand même un peu
surprenant quoi donc on a toujours les
accords égalité homme femme on a tous
ces accords là mais celui là on l'a plus
alors qu'effectivement il ya deux sujets
etc j'allais exactement exprimer ce que
vous dites c'est à dire que l'on n'a
plus les personnes âgées dans le cercle
familial on essaye de les sortir le plus
vite possible
probablement aussi parce que quand on
accompagne d'une personne âgée qui est
chez nous il faut du temps et les gens
n'ont plus de temps il faut que ça aille
vite ça évitera éviter à ces une
personne âgée donc là on n'est plus dans
le grand âge on n'a pas de temps à lui
accordé parce que ça va passer vite et
qu'il faut être patient il faut de
l'espace
le lot des grands débats et mme avenir
dans les années qui viennent c'est pas
la retraite et la dépendance
le débat le plus difficile je pense à
régler ça déjà c'est sûr là c'est sur la
table c'est sur la tendresse encore
essentiel oui mais en émettant dans les
ehpad je trouve ça absolument horrible
parce qu'on ne sait pas donc c'est
comment ils sont des usines à vieux la
problématique sur la discrimination vous
parliez de personnes -des entre 55 et 60
ans qui essaie d'envoyer des cv
absolument car ils trouveront pas de
travail et ça c'est un vrai problème de
discrimination donc la discrimination
sur ces jeunes qui essayent de également
de discriminer les vieux je trouve que
c'est extrêmement choquant la raison
comment la france était encore un pays
rural y avait plus de places dans les
maisons on pouvait accueillir ce qui est
vrai que sur qui habitent dans les
villes aujourd'hui c'est vous aussi
comme beaucoup plus difficile et puis
auparavant c'étaient les enfants qui
habitaient chez la personne âgée
donc on avait tout la cellule qui
restait alors aux parler de la grève
tout à l'heure évidemment il ya beaucoup
de gens qui marchent à plein avec de
larges marches du marché c'est vrai
beaucoup de gens qui marchent et donc il
ya des gens qui sont pas contrôlés d'un
qui est très très contents parce qu'il
dit je crois qu'il travaillait paris il
habite à la verrière et il fait 70
kilomètres km par jour
oui oui alors il faut dire que c'est un
spécialiste il est
les marathoniens non c'est assez amusant
c'est pas mal
donc j'ai doublé l'uss dans les bourgs
ou abcès devrait passer quelques
quelques est valable ou voilà il veille
par deux chez olivier
et puis il fait ses 30 km comme quoi
tout le monde n'est pas malheureux
d'avoir de la marche à pied à la havane
la moyenne quotidienne pour saint
jacques de compostelle à regarder à
regarder après at on s'aperçoit qu'il a
oublié
[Rires]
voilà on peut être heureux et votre
marchand heureux band of été réservé aux
marcheurs et j'avais les crocs nous a
tous dit le dessus passer au débat il
nous reste quatre minutes mais c'était
intéressant de 2,6 reporter on en avait
déjà parlé je sais pas si vous avez lu
l'interview polanski dans paris match à
bordeaux parle c'est le débat alors
revendre pas lorsqu'il parle encore
d'une interview à paris match dans
lequel il se défend absolument des faits
qui lui sont reprochés
c'est facile d'accuser quand les faits
sont prescrits qu'il n'y aura pas de
procès d'hier pour me disculper latérite
et j'ai trouvé assez touchante mais j'ai
pas si vous l'avez regardé plus que
touchant parce qu'il ya vraiment des
choses qui me paraissent assez juste la
phrase qu'on vient de voir effectivement
c'est vrai que le mal est fait tout le
monde enfin la majorité des gens pensent
que polanski
violer ces deux femmes il n'a aucun
moyen de dire que c'est faux et c'est
parce que ça ne s'agira pas plus loin
donc c'est effectivement quelque chose
de terrible et c'est vrai que le
mouvement mitu enfin balance son port et
ses a débouché sur des tas de choses
bien évidemment passionnante une prise
de parole et une mise en valeur de
pratiques évidemment contestable et
scandaleuse et et criminels en tout cas
des délictuelles mais il ya aussi
beaucoup de gens de lancer le nom en
pâture et puis après on dit un an après
il ya ba oui finalement c'est peut-être
pas vrai mais ça y est le mec est mort
médiatiquement mais rien n'assure qu'il
porte contre weinstein dont il dit il
est il a déterré la fed ce avantage à
main qui était donc cette jeune femme
alors là il dit je n'ai jamais endormi
les âmes et drogué contrairement à ce
qu'on a dit ne s'est jamais avoué sa et
di valle a déterré cette affaire pour
m'éliminer aux oscars parce qu'il avait
un autre film placé ce qui n'est pas
vraiment facile et fière d'avoir n'avait
pas empêché d'avoir l'oscar de metteur
en scène pour le pianiste
le pianiste ben non sur cet album il a
raison de dire que le luth ont changé
roman polanski est un octogénaire et qui
attendent à l'été donne c'est connu
n'était pas dans la même époque
il a connu les années d'insouciance
enfin les années où il n'y avait pas le
sida et il dit que c'est le sida qui a
changé qui a acquis et qui a durci sous
le plan sur le plan moral par les
relations il est bien évident que dans
les années soit dans les années de la
jeunesse de polanski ont sifflé l'on
pouvait siffler une fille on pouvait
sortir en boîte est rentrée à
chez soi enfin il y avait une espèce de
frivolité d'un jeu sexuel
alors on peut donner ce concept qui est
très sociologique pas trouvé mais je
préfère parler de de frivolité
d'insouciance de aujourd'hui vous
sifflez une fille dans la rue ça
s'appelle du harcèlement voulu fait un
compliment faut surtout pas le faire
parce que là on rentre dans l'ennui
touré effectivement polanski a raison de
dire on a changé d'époque
je vais me reprocher quelque chose qui
était on va pas reprocher une époque
au contraire on regrette cette époque
mais on accuse des gens qui vivaient
même s'il a une prédilection quand même
pour les filles à ces jeunes
oui mais après regardez ma jeunesse
souvenez-vous de base novateur est très
rare ostroff et au design toujours
disait qu'elle était formidable
j'aimerais sortir les journalistes qui
ont fait des papiers sur les romans de
masse nef qui parler des petites filles
en disant que c'était superbe et c'était
magnifique
ces journalistes vivent toujours ils ont
fait quand même l'apologie d'un crime de
aujourd'hui d'un crime si vous voulez
donc les temps ont changé et la liste on
fait l'apologie d'un roman de geneviève
dormann qui s'appelle la main histoire
quand même d'une d'une quadragénaire
enfin on dirait maintenant peut-être une
cougar qui passent une nuit avec 1 1
un gamin de 13 ans mais dans son lit et
tout le bouquin est magnifique c'est
aussi des peuples vous en parler on peut
reprendre le bouquin de cohn bendit où
il a quand même des phrases assez
curieuse sur le quai la casino thérapie
auprès des enfants de 5 ans enfin voilà
donc c'est l'époque disait justement ils
ont libéré les enfants il faut leur
apprendre la sexualité c'est donc
rapidement parce que et rapidement ce
qui est intéressant c'est effectivement
il dit on me juge sur une certaine
époque avec les critères d'aujourd'hui
exactement donc ça c'est
c'est je suis à 100 pc jeanne défaut de
l'époque je posterai alors je bats
parler de givet le dorman et là on va
parler de jean pierre lecoq la caresse
des orties c'est à 15h un très bon très
bon roman policier de facture classique
donc rassurante ya pas de d'éventration
n'y a pas de salle qui leur on a un
héros récurrent qui est un commissaire
de police qui fait très bien son nom son
travail et qui la sauve à se balader
surtout dans les ardennes avec une bière
blonde histoire comment c'est pas drôle
berne aussi dans le béarn
non pas celui là celui là il ya un cri
dans le béarn
non mais je crois que vous l'avez lu ça
fait plaisir donc il ya un crime rêver
mais le l'enquète se déroule
principalement dans les ardennes vous
aidera mis en examen dans le béarn et
madame merci beaucoup je dis merci
beaucoup s'étaient fait bon saut
christof buri affluence hier à la baisse
et a très vite peut-être pour nouveau
parfum
[Musique]